after that did covington the other thing
is after this too if let's say lebron
james is ruled to be inbounds
[Music]
does covington knock it out of bounds
here
[Music]
after it hits his left hand
yeah that's out that's out
after a view the right foot of lebron
james was down out of bounds when his
hands were in contact with the
basketball okay this happened prior to
the out of bounds by covington the
challenge by the clippers is successful
it is la bowl
[Music]
they wanted to be sure
lebron james is coming over now to talk
to to rj
how can you challenge a player that's
not called on the floor
i i think that i
you asking the wrong player bro
i i'm with you but i think that's what
the call was coming to knocking the ball
off
and challenges say that you were out
well they were trying to challenge to
see if you were out first
i think you can review the whole play in
that situation when when
they touch that but frank vogel is
arguing that frank vogel has the same
argument that lebron james does we're
back in a moment it's clifford ball
[Music]
the ball was still in the bronze hand
when his right foot touched out of
bounds so they put a couple seconds back
on the clock there's a two and a half
second difference between the game and
shot clocks and the clippers were in
danger
awfully close to an eight-second
backcourt violation but the lakers are
called for a foul
with one second to spare that is that is
look zak zarb is one of the best in the
business but here
i i i well the problem is right there
zach it deems that they're trying to
foul that's what they're trying to so
right there that's not a foul but
they're deeming that the lakers are
trying to foul
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
violation what are you doing it's gonna
be laker ball
this is not sure what reggie jackson was
thinking there
gotta get it ahead
give the lakers credit for guarding that
mid court line but why would you throw
the ball back there you only had 1.2
seconds to get it across
don't understand that at all neither
does ty lou so it's gonna be laker ball
down one with 17.8 remaining are there
any more reviews just let me know
are there any more reviews possible
wow
here's james
21 points
covington is on him they've been drawing
all game
lebron with 10. lakers down one here
comes the double james gives it up
anthony
rainbow short rebound covington lakers
have to foul and they do with 2.2
remaining
but even if the free throws go and it's
a three-point lead
lakers do not have a time-out to advance
the ball
what'd you think of the shot
just the play you're disappointed look
obviously braun has three players on him
if you're carmelo you can go you can do
anything but that is a deep d3 we know
carmelo has that range but with that
amount of time that's a deep deep shot
you only need you need a bucket if you
put your head down and try and get
something but i also think that lebron
james took too long to get into that set
because now with that shot now you have
two seconds
and it makes it very very difficult
this very similar game to the laker
clipper contest
it was a clipper home game back on
february 3rd but there were six lead
changes in the final minute reggie
jackson was the hero at the end of that
game he was almost the goat with the uh
the turnover the eight second backward
violation now he's a chance to hit
another free throw and give the clippers
a three-point lead and again the lakers
are out of time out so they can't
advance the ball 2.2 seconds left
jackson hits
see if the lakers try to throw it down
court here
horton tucker will
broken up out of bounds it actually
helps out
you got time the lakers don't have a
timeout to set anything up but seven
tenths of a second left so you got time
for a catch and shoot three
but now frank vogel is trying to direct
guys without timeout this actually helps
the fact that they're inbounding are
they're substituting a player giving
lakers a little bit more time to get set
well clippers are bringing in
hartenstein they're bringing in
some size here
i i think the only thing you can do is
let lebron break to the corner
there it is james falling away at three
comes up short and the clippers get a
huge win
105 102 that six straight wins for the
clippers over the lakers the clippers
are at 500 the lakers are now five games
under
lakers had their chances and here you
knew it break to the corner like you
said
that was the one shot just short
the lakers just ran out of steam late
but good look there
and lebron streak of 25 point games
comes to an end
he finishes with 21. he needed three
there to tie he couldn't